Here, in case you haven't noticed it,
there is a war going on out there.
And you women started, oh, no,
we did not. But that is a typical male attitude.
Now, the truth is
that we women haven't had enough power
or money or confidence to start much of anything,
but we sure as heck get the blame for everything.
I'll tell you something else.
I love men. I love this one.
But you cannot ignore history.
History has shown that in general,
it has been the men who have done the raping and the robbing
and the killing and the war mongering for the last 2,000 years.
It has been the men who have done the pillaging and the beheading
and the subjugating of whole races into slavery.
It has been the men who have done the law making and the money making
and most of the mischief making.
So if the world isn't quite what you had in mind,
you have only yourselves to thank.